okay hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others and i think um
we have a bunch of questions here
uh all right let's start off
with one from d96
when an electron moves from one energy
level to another and releases a photon
is the direction of the photon random
okay so let's explain roughly what's
going on there
so in an atom there are there's a
nucleus that's made of protons and a
positive charge and neutrons that have
zero charge
and then there are electrons that are
kind of going around the nucleus
the nucleus uh the electrons the nucleus
is
quite small the the average distance
that the electrons are is like a hundred
thousand times
the size of the nucleus so
but there's this kind of cloud of
electrons around the nucleus
and the way that one describes how those
electrons
sort of exist around the nucleus uses
quantum mechanics
and uh in fact in our in our new theory
of
fundamental physics we're sort of slowly
getting to the point where there may be
a very much easier way to describe
what's going on with those electrons but
but roughly
what's happening is normally one might
think oh there's
something that's orbiting something else
there's a there's an electron that has
negative charge so it's attracted to the
the protons which have positive charge
and nucleus
the thing is just going around and it's
swinging around like a satellite would
go around the earth
uh being being sort of kept in orbit by
in the case of
the satellite around the earth by
gravity in the case of the electron
going around the nucleus by electric
forces
so that will be kind of the classical
physics picture of what's going on
in quantum mechanics the key thing
is that there isn't a definite
trajectory that things move along
instead things in a sense move along all
possible trajectories
and there's a certain there's a certain
likelihood
that they follow each particular
trajectory and we don't kind of get to
know what that likelihood is
until we make specific measurements and
so on and there's a whole elaborate
theory of quantum mechanics which i
think we are managing to
to understand a lot more clearly it's a
fascinating subject
but um let me not divert into talking
about that
but one feature of quantum mechanics is
that it tells one that electrons as they
go
around the nucleus can exist only
in have only particular amounts of
energy
so when something is in orbit let's say
a satellite is an orbit around the earth
it has a certain amount of energy
kinetic energy energy associated with
motion
that it gets from the fact that it's
moving around the earth
and the amount of kinetic energy that it
has is in that case just proportional to
the square of the velocity
of the thing going around its orbit and
um
so the if you have a satellite in orbit
around the earth
the satellite can have depends on the
the uh
the elevation of the orbit um
affects the kinetic energy but basically
you can have a satellite with any
possible
value of kinetic energy orbiting the
earth well up to some limit but at which
point it will
escape from the earth but actually that
well
a little bit there's some there's some
trickiness there but basically
you can have the um you can um uh you
can have it have any kinetic energy you
want just like if you
if you take something and it's on a
string and you're whirling it around
with your
your hand um you know up to the point
where the string breaks or some other
crazy thing happens
uh you can make it go more slowly you
can make it go faster
that's the usual way things work in
classical mechanics
in quantum mechanics it works
differently and they're only a discrete
quantized set of energy levels that are
possible
and there are a variety of ways to
understand why that happens
roughly the um uh well
the typical way that uses the standard
mathematical formalism of quantum
mechanics
uses the thing called the schrodinger
equation and basically what happens is
that the description of electrons in an
atom um are described by a so-called
wave function
and that wave function has the feature
that it kind of
is it's it's its values are a little bit
like the displacement
of a string that um would be
uh sort of plucked so for example if we
have a string
and it's attached to its two ends and
you pluck it
in the middle then one possibility is
the string just goes up and comes down
again
mathematically it would be you know sine
pi x
or something the other possibility is
that the string
has uh has sort of two maxima so it goes
up
and down down and up again so that would
be mathematically signed you know 2 pi x
or something like that
and in general you can have a string
that has any number
of those maxima sine 3 pi x etc sine 4
pi x
those when we look at the frequency with
which the string is vibrating
that will go up in the case of a sort of
ideal string
that will go up by integer amounts so
it'll be either
the fundamental frequency or frequency
times two times three times four times
five
etc okay so the um
when you have the string it's kind of
possible
frequencies are quantized um that's just
a feature of the fact that it can have
one wiggle two wiggle three wheels
it can't have two and a half wiggles
because that wouldn't end it up
with something where you can where it
will be
uh sort of attached at its two ends it
would have half a wiggle
that sort of overshoots the attachment
points at the end so it has to be
quantized into a fixed number of wiggles
okay so in quantum mechanics through
schroeder's equation through this wave
function idea
the same thing happens with electrons
their wave functions
have to be kind of arranged so that they
kind of
within the size of the atom in some
sense
they can only wiggle a fixed number of
times
and so what that means is uh in the case
of electrons the the frequency of the
wiggles on the string
translates into the energy of the
electron and so that means is that there
are discrete energy levels for the
electron
in the atom so again whirling something
around on a string or having a satellite
orbit the earth
there aren't a fixed discrete set of
energy levels
there can be any energy you want but in
an atom
the the electrons can have only a fixed
set of possible energy levels
okay so when if you
heat up an atom by literally putting it
in you know
having it be bouncing around
with uh hitting other molecules hitting
other atoms and so on
as you would when you literally heat it
up it increases temperature
one of the things that can happen then
is that the the electrons in the atom
can get pushed into higher energy levels
excited states but then
those excited states again as a result
of quantum mechanics and this now
requires
to do it properly requires so-called
quantum electrodynamics
uh quantum field theory um but uh you
can sort of approximate it with sort of
ordinary
quantum mechanics there's a certain uh
there's a certain probability
that that electron that's in its excited
state
will uh emit a photon and go to a lower
state
so always these are discrete states
so for example in the in the simple case
of a hydrogen atom
there's just uh one proton in the in the
nucleus
and one electron kind of in orbit so to
speak
the uh in the first approximation the
energy levels
of the hydrogen atom uh go like some
constant minus
well one over n squared so the nth level
uh the the the that that determines
that's the kind of mathematical formula
which determines where the energy levels
are as as
it gets to the point where you put so
much energy into the electron eventually
the electron will escape the nucleus
and at that point the the one over n
squared the n gets very big the levels
get very very close together
and that's kind of a representation of
where you are about to hit so-called
ionization
where the electron will escape from the
nucleus but normally
there are these energy levels that are
separa that that have
defined by these just mathematical
numbers and uh
their discrete energy levels okay so
then
the photons that get emitted are emitted
by
white transitions from one energy level
to another so in the case of hydrogen
there are famous named transitions like
the so-called lyman alpha lines
those correspond to photons that are
being emitted
when they make a transition from one
particular energy level to another
particular energy level you
emit in that case ultraviolet photons
that are important for astronomy in that
case but every
every for hydrogen is sort of a famous
element um
that some of those things are actually
named um but in general
the the uh what what's happening is
you're making a transition from one
quantized energy level to another
and so if you have lots of different
energy levels there might be many
different transitions that can be made
from one energy level to another from
another one to another
there are lots of different uh um
energies of photons that can be emitted
okay so when the submission happens so
you've excited
you you you made the electron go to this
excited state
it is going to decay down and emit a
photon to go to a different
uh to go to a different state maybe to
the lowest state the ground state
perhaps or maybe to some other excited
state
but it's going to emit a photon okay so
the question that was asked was when it
emits a photon
when it spontaneously emits a photon
that's some
spontaneous emission of photons that's
um
when you have a laser there's stimulated
emission of radiation that's
that's not spontaneous emission it works
in a different way
but when you have an ordinary atom
that's been sort of thermally excited by
just increasing its temperature
the the emission of photons is this
spontaneous emission of photons
and there's a certain uh depending on
exactly the details of the atom
there'll be a certain rate at which that
emission occurs
okay photon is emitted where does the
photon go
well so just as the question of when the
photon will be emitted is
is random but follows a distribution it
follows an exponential
decay law um so similarly the direction
that the photon is going to be emitted
is also random but it's a little
trickier than that
because and this is where gosh if i can
explain this i'll be pleased with myself
um the uh okay
it turns out that it depends on which
energy level of the electron and is the
is it's starting from and which energy
level it's ending up with
that affects the angular distribution
the the um uh what what direction
the um uh the photon what what the
distribution of directions that the
photon will go
in is now uh again
oh boy this gets more and more
complicated okay
so you have an atom and you might say
well the atom
is just like spherically symmetric it's
like any direction you can rotate the
atom anyway
and there's no real difference between
different different sides of the atom
that's not always true because an atom
can be spinning
on its axis and it can have an angular
momentum
that's spinning around like the earth
spins on its axis
and has sort of a definite in the case
of the earth it has sort of a definite
pole
and you know where it's spinning around
in the case of atoms quantum mechanics
says it's a little bit more subtle than
that but there can be this notion of
so-called quantized angular momentum
so just like the energy levels are
quantized so also the angular momentum
is quantized
so it can have zero units of angular
momentum uh half a unit one unit
uh it happens to go in half units okay
so it can have let's just say zero unit
one unit
actually for these purposes uh for the
purposes i'm now describing
one unit is right um the half unit has
to do with what happens with electrons
specifically
but um so it can have zero units of
angular momentum it's actually
the units that are used are units of
planck's constant over
two pi but that's irrelevant so h bar is
the name of that
that thing so it's it's kind of zero h
bar
units of angle momentum one h bar two h
bar and so on
okay so essentially what's happening is
as it gets more momentum it's as if the
thing is spinning on its axis
faster and faster that's not really
quite how it works quantum mechanics has
a slightly more subtle thing that goes
on
to represent this kind of angular
momentum but as soon as you have angular
momentum
you have an axis defined you have you
know there's a north pole there's a
definite direction so to speak
and then you can start asking is the
when the photon is emitted
where is that photon going relative to
the direction
of that angular momentum and so
what happens is there are some photons
that are emitted where they just don't
care
about the direction of angular momentum
and there's some photons emitted where
they will
tend where they will care about the
direction and in particular
there is as you look as you get higher
and higher angular momentum
there will in a sense be more or more
possibility of caring about which
direction you're going in
because roughly what happens is as you
get
uh and i'm going to make another math
formula here
as you get angular momentum j the the
number of different possible states of
the atom is two j
plus one um so uh and that means that
um in some sense there are there are
sort of
more different possible uh
ways in which the photon can be emitted
and so it cares more about the specific
direction it's emitted in
now it turns out as you look at these
uh these sort of as you as you say
consider higher angular momentum
the um uh the different
uh sort of the the angular distribution
when the n momentum is zero
the angular distribution is like i don't
care which direction i'm going in
it's equally probable that the photon
goes in all directions
when the angular momentum is um
uh let's say the next level up
is i think it's
three cosine squared theta minus one if
i remember correctly
is the um is the next so so basically
what happens is
um the um oh gosh this is
this is i i'm uh it gets kind of
complicated kind of quickly but but let
me let me
say a little bit more mathematically
because it might be interesting to
people
um if you know about sines and cosines
they are uh
they represent kind of if you if you are
looking at things around a circle if
you're saying i have
this density at different points around
a circle you can always represent that
as well you've got this amount of sine
theta stuff this amount of sine two
theta stuff sine three theta and so on
the corresponding thing for three
dimensions on a sphere are things called
spherical harmonics
and the distribution of intensities of
photons
at a given uh with with atoms with a
given
angular momentum is determined by these
spherical harmonics
and as you go to higher momentum higher
angular momentum
the spherical harmonics correspond that
correspond to the angular distribution
of photons
get more and more peaked around
different directions
so so that's that's more or less how it
works um so so the answer
in the end is um the the distribution
depends on the spin of the not the spin
the angular momentum
of the um uh of the atom
and things about the angular momentum
associated with these different energy
levels and that will determine whether
the thing is uniformly distributed
or whether it has a an angular
distribution which somehow follows the
direction
of the the the sort of the axis of
angular momentum for the atom
so that's that's basically how it works
so i'll tell you one
one little extra piece of sort of trivia
in a sense about emission of things from
atoms
so you can look at uh things like photon
emission for an atom
but when you have radioactive decay you
can have other kinds of emission from
at least the nucleus so a famous kind of
of radioactive decay is beta decay so in
beta decay the nucleus
uh what happens is basically roughly a
neutron in the nucleus
decays into a proton an electron and an
antineutrino
okay and so what you'll actually see is
the nucleus will sort of self-destruct
with with one of its
particles um you know
transmuting into into something
different and an electron will be
emitted and
neutrino which is this very light uh
very
hard to detect particle will also be
emitted and so the
electron will come out in one direction
and the neutrino will come out in
basically the opposite direction just to
conserve momentum
okay so one of the big questions
was a sort of a basic question about the
universe
is is the universe what's called parity
invariant
so that means if you take a picture of
something that's happening in the
universe
you say this is a this is a valid
picture of something that happened these
particles collided they did this they
did that
and then somebody says let's invert that
picture let's
let's just um essentially reflect it in
a mirror let's let's make
let's let's just switch around all the
all the directions so everything that
was uh
was going one direction now goes in the
exact opposite direction
okay is that after you make that parity
transformation
can you tell whether the image that you
had is still a valid image that could
exist in our universe
in other words is the universe invariant
under space inversion or parity
or parity transformation is this picture
you could say
no that's wrong that couldn't possibly
happen in our universe or is it the case
that if if one version of it worked
then the version where everything was
inverted would also work so
back uh before well i'm kind of
the the in when quantum mechanics was
first being developed
people thought the universe is invariant
under parity transformations
so in the 1930s 1940s if you ask
somebody does the universe
have the symmetry that every process is
invariant under parity inversion
they've said yup that's the case okay
until 1956
in 1956 an experiment was done
on beta decay which discovered that the
universe is not invariant
under parity conversion and the way that
was that experiment was done
was in this case the atomic nucleus had
an angular momentum
and then the question was is the angular
distribution of emission of electrons
uh uh invariant under changing the
under inverting the direction of the of
a momentum i didn't really explain why
this is the case but
but um uh it's it's the case that that
that is a condition for this parity
inversion working
is that the angular distribution should
not care
whether the whether the the axis is
pointing sort of up or down it should be
it should have it should be the
distribution of directions that
electrons should go on
should be symmetric under being aligned
with the axis or anti-alignment of the
axis
okay so in 1956 some people i think in
new york
um did this experiment on uh
oh i can't remember what is it uh which
element
hmm memory failed on that one um
but anyway on a radioactive decay beta
decay
um and they discovered that no actually
it wasn't symmetric under under uh
inversion up and down
so that proved that the universe is not
invariant under parity inversion
and um why was that how do we sort of
understand that now
well the reason we understand that now
is because neutrinos
which have an angular momentum they have
a spin the
the the reason that we can see this is
basically all neutrinos
are pretty close to exactly left-handed
that is
the direction if the neutrino is going
in some direction this
the spin of the neutrino is always
aligned so that it's kind of curling
around like the fingers on one's left
hand
and not like the fingers on one's right
hand so the neutrino
kind of knows that the neutrino is
fundamentally not
invariant under the parity inversion and
um okay things get a little bit more
subtle the anti-neutrino is then
right-handed
and that's then there's another level of
this kind of question about in
about some invariants under inversion
and uh while
the universe was known in 1956 not to be
invariant under parity inversion
people thought that it was still
invariant under a combination of parity
inversion
and so-called charge conjugation where
you take neutrino
and you make it into an anti-neutrino
you make every particle to its
anti-particle
and you do the space inversion people
thought that was still at symmetry of
the universe
until 1964 when it was discovered in the
somewhat obscure in the decay of the k-0
meson
it was discovered that um in fact there
was a a violation of cp invariants of
combined charge conjugation and parity
and variance and so then that was known
not to be a symmetry of the universe
but then the one surviving symmetry is
so-called cpt
invariants which is the combined
invariance under charge conjugation
space inversion and time reversal and
that
invariance is pretty much guaranteed by
theory of relativity and if it isn't
true
then all kinds of funky things happen
now an interesting question is whether
it's true in our fundamental theory of
physics
whether it's true at extremely small
scales in the universe
and the answer is it will not be exactly
true it will be something that is only
true
um when we uh when we get to very large
scales
um and uh uh it's something that will be
um that that's only um
uh uh that's emerges as true
when you look at a large scale but if
you look at sufficiently small scales if
you look right down at the level where
you can see that space is discrete
it will no longer be true so there's
sort of some interesting things there
and
actually it occurs to me that um i'm
about to work on a bunch of things to do
with the experimental consequences
of our models of physics and i should
actually look at the
uh whether cpt and violation
can be amplified around particularly
spinning black holes
which might happen in our models okay
note to self that i should look at that
um so thanks for asking that question
because it led me to this
um okay
let's see so that was a very long answer
to this question from d96
about um uh direction of photons random
see
these things get kind of complicated i
mean if if you want to know
perhaps it's interesting for people to
know sort of the
official no maybe not i mean i i could
tell you sort of the
the official lingo of what what of how
you'd answer that question
but but i don't think perhaps i think i
think i gave you the basic description
here
um
okay let's see
um i see is asking how do you remember
all those formulas the formula i was
quoting actually
is uh those are legendre polynomials and
i think i remember the first two
genre polynomials um and uh
the um those are yeah um
um let's see
there are some questions here
oh there's a question from settor can
you explain inertial versus non-inertial
reference frames
um okay
so let's first of all set some
some kind of um uh the real question is
if you are in an elevator for example or
you're in a you're in a closed box and
you're just doing things in that closed
box you're
you're doing a bunch of physics
experiments you're doing this you're
doing that
the question is close box you can't see
outside
and the question is if that box
is traveling at a high rate of speed in
some direction
can you tell in other words in the
closed box
can you tell what if you're just going
at a certain speed
without any acceleration you're just you
know you're you're in
you're you're freely moving at a certain
speed can you tell what speed you're
moving at
so einstein's special theory of
relativity its big point is you
can't tell but you only can't tell
if there is no uh
if you're in so-called inertial motion
if you're in if it's just so okay so
newton's first law says
a body that is put in motion will stay
in the same state of motion
unless it's acted on by an external
force now there's some slight of hand in
the way that that definition is made
because it's sort of a definition of
force and it's not clear
what it really sort of says but what it
means operationally is
if you're forget the earth forget having
gravity where things fall
forget all those kinds of things imagine
you're out in space between the galaxies
there's essentially no gravity from
anything well there's always
there would be some some gravity but
essentially there are no
sort of gravitational effects and you're
out in intergalactic space
and you throw a ball well and it's in a
vacuum and everything the ball will just
keep going in a straight line
it will just that is what newton's first
law says
and that's that's what um uh that's
that's what will happen
now that um so that that's a um
uh that's that's what's usually called
inertial motion
it's moving just according to its
inertia it's not acted on by some
external force
now if the ball if you threw the ball
near the surface of the earth
we know ignore air resistance and all
that kind of thing
the ball will fall down because of the
effect of gravity
from the earth okay so similarly you're
in your closed box
and you're asking the question am i near
the earth am i in intergalactic space
well you can tell if you're near the
earth or if you're in intergalactic
space
because you're um the um
the ball will if you're near the earth
the ball will fall down
in some direction associated with the
gravity of the earth if you're an
intergalactic space
the ball will just sit there and and and
will not fall
so so the the the concept of an inertial
frame inertial
inertial motion um is the concept
of if you're in a place where there's
sort of no forces acting
um and you're just moving in the way
that inertia would have you move
then that's what corresponds to an
inertial frame now you can get
an inertial frame even when you have uh
something
when you're when you have gravity there
if you're in free fall
like the you're an elevator in the
elevators just you know
if you're if if you know that's the bad
scenario for an elevator but but um
uh you know if you're just if your box
is just freely falling in the gravity of
the earth
um then you also are in this in this
inertial state
um where you are not that maybe is a
confusing case so
forget that case for now let's consider
the case where
you just no force is acting on you
that's
then you kind of um you can't tell what
speed you're going at
everything will work the same if you are
in a
uh if so then the sort of second level
of things that leads to general
relativity is
associated with this so-called principle
of equivalence which
says that there are when when things
fall if you if you drop your ball if you
in in your box and the ball falls
why is the ball falling well there are
two possible explanations one is you're
in a gravitational field
and the other is that your box is
accelerating in some direction
and so the principle of equivalence is
about essentially the equivalence
between
sort of being in a gravitational field
and having this acceleration
imposed on you and and so the the idea
of a
non-inertial frame is something where
there is something like a a
gravitational field
that's associated with um
uh with with your um uh that's there
or alternatively that there's some
acceleration some
some force that is pushing you to change
your state of motion
so things needless to say get
unbelievably much more subtle
than this um the the whole question of
what it means
to be in a certain state of motion and
so on
depends on how you're measuring what is
motion
motion is you're changing your position
in space
as a function of time but what is your
position in space
well you have to be able to mark off
different
points in space so let's say you have a
meter rule
physical you know hard meter rule you
can say
you're moving from one place on the
meter rule to another that's all easy to
understand
but let's say there is no meter rule
let's say that you are defining points
in space
by some procedure let's say you have
light signals bouncing back and forth
and you're using that to sort of
virtually create a meter rule well
things get
extremely much more subtle when you do
things like that
and typically what happens is people
initially uh start thinking about well
in these situations where there's a
gravitational field for example the
gravitational field of a black hole
in an extreme case which is a strong
gravitational field
um there is a uh this there's sort of a
this question of of what counts as
different places in space and how do you
put down coordinates
that represent what's going on in space
what what the different places in space
are
it's extremely subtle in fact confused
people
from about 1915 up until pretty much the
1960s
how you would put down those coordinates
for something where you had a strong
gravitational field
um so that uh and this question about
what kind of
non-inertial frame you're in and what
counts as motion and what counts of
gravitational field and so on
very subtle kinds of issues um that uh
eventually get untangled they're
actually
somewhat clearer in our model of
fundamental physics
but to explain that i kind of have to go
and start talking
about um sort of the discrete uh
structure that lies underneath space
time and that gets us off in a whole
different direction
but um in um uh gosh
in our theories of physics the notion
let me not go here i can talk about
inertial versus non-inertial frames
there
but um i mean i can i can say the words
it all has to do with
um uh anti-chains and partially ordered
sets that correspond to the causal
graphs of evolution
in our models but but let me i can i can
unpack that but that will take me a
solid 15 minutes to unpack
and i want to try and get onto some
other questions so maybe another time i
can talk about that
um
let's see there's a question from
amarita
why do humans have an appendix even
though it is unnecessary
so what is the appendix you know inside
our intestines
there's this kind of dead end where
there's sort of a a pocket of intestines
and
and unfortunately things sometimes get
stuck there and then you get
appendicitis
and um you get infection there and so on
and that's that's a bad thing
and uh when you uh you know
you have surgery for for appendicitis
you just sort of snip off that part of
the intestine and make it a you know a
smooth
as a smooth bend rather than something
that has a little pocket in it
and it seems like it doesn't do anybody
any harm to do that
and it seems like why would there be a
weird pocket where where stuff can
get stuck and get infected just seems
like a bad idea
um so how do things like that happen in
biology
so there are two branches to the answer
to that question
one branch is uh you say it's
unnecessary
but has it really always been
unnecessary that's branch number one
and branch number two is you know the
way that
biological organisms get designed
is not by a process of kind of people
thinking about the design
at least not yet it's more a process of
biological evolution
where random changes get made and if
one form of the organism is more
successful than another and has more
more progeny more children than the
other then it will be the one that wins
out
okay so let's first of all take the
branch of is it really unnecessary
okay so one of the things that
happens rather often in biology is
people say uh
oh i don't know what that does it must
be
unnecessary so for example people said
that about large parts of the brain
people said that about large parts of
the genome we don't know what it does
it seems unnecessary the part of the
function of that thing
that we understand you know 90 percent
of
the thing doesn't contribute to that
function so it seems unnecessary
so you know when it comes to now is that
really right
well a couple of reasons why it might
not be right one is you might just have
not understood what that other 90 does
it might be something where like in in
the case of the genome it might be
something that's important for kind of
the structure of the the you know the
way that the
molecules actually organize themselves
and which parts get activated and which
parts are close to each other
and these things that seem like they're
unnecessary because they're not
relevant to actually but let's say
making
proteins which is the function that we
initially know that the genome is
performing
they're not necessary for that but they
are necessary for something we didn't
yet understand
so the first thing is when we say it's
unnecessary might be wrong
now the second thing is unnecessary now
is different from unnecessary throughout
history throughout the history of our
species
so for example now if you live in
sort of the the um uh you know some
sort of fancy place it's pretty unlikely
you will get
parasites in your gut it's pretty you
know
you eat food that's been you know that's
been passed by
uh you know food inspectors and all this
kind of thing
you're you're very unlikely uh uh you
know unless
unless something bad happens you're very
unlikely to
to uh uh to end up with parasites now if
you live in a place
where that isn't what's going on i've
visited some such places i've
managed to get infected not with
parasites but with other kinds of things
from
from food um it's you know it's very
common
for one to have in many countries in the
world
it's common for people to end up
with parasites um in their gut now in a
sense that sounds very scary
but in some sense it shouldn't be scary
because in our gut
the um uh there are many bacteria that
live in our gut
and that's the normal way that things
work the bacteria
are are doing things that are useful to
us we all have a so-called microbiome
that consists of populations of all
kinds of bacteria and depending on
exactly what kind of food you eat
you'll increase or decrease the number
of some kind of bacterium
and so on different people will have
different microbiomes
if you take antibiotics you zap out a
whole bunch of those
those some those bacteria because
antibiotics attack bacteria
and that may be something which will put
your microbiome
out of whack for months um and uh
and sometimes your microbiome can be in
some state where you know some
particular species of bacteria has worn
out
so in some sense those bacteria are like
uh parasites living in our gut except
that
they're actually they're pretty good for
us and they're important for the um
for the way that we digest food and so
on and and probably for other functions
too
but uh usually when we talk about
parasites it's protozoa
um not um uh uh i think usually things
like amoebas and so on
um not um uh not bacteria although you
can get infected
with bacteria in your gut where it's
bacteria that aren't
the kind of bacteria that sort of should
be in your microbiome
but they're things which are a sort of a
a foreign bacteria and that's a bad
thing
and you can end up with um so anyway
the point is there are there's all kinds
of stuff
that if you're in a fancy place where
there are food inspectors making sure
there aren't any
any sort of parasites in your food
you'll end up with
a microbiome with lots of um bacteria in
your gut but not presumably protozoa and
things like that
and in that environment well you know
seems like appendix the appendix is
quite is doesn't
doesn't have any important consequence
um i don't know
for sure whether in some scenario where
there was some particular kind of
weird you know uh parasite maybe the
appendix is important in that case
maybe it's something which no it's not
important if you live in a place with
food inspectors
but it is important if you're living in
a place where you could easily get those
kinds of parasites
so to say not important is something
which may be a
feature of just the last you know
hundred years
of you know food inspected places in the
world so to speak
so so that's one one branch of is it
really necessary
and so on it may be that you know uh
it isn't necessary to you because the
way you live but it would be necessary
if you if you lived in a place where
the the sort of the diet and and um and
and sanitation and so on was very
different um i don't
know that to be the case for the
appendix i don't think it necessarily is
but
it um uh it's something where you know
that's something which is always the
thing you have to think about
is you know was this useful uh
even if it wasn't useful today was it
useful 10 000 years ago in the history
of our species because
we haven't evolved that far from over
the last 10 000 years
okay so the second issue is maybe it is
that way
because when you when the organism grows
the you know the gut is being formed in
a certain way and
you know it it's twisting itself up in
some ways and that's just left over as
kind of a construction artifact
that is it's like when you build a
certain kind of building
you know you may have to in order to get
something on the roof of that building
you may have to build some whole
scaffolding
and it's like well you could just take
the scaffolding down get rid of it
but maybe you'll leave the scaffolding
up and if you leave the scaffolding up
then you say what's the use of that
scaffolding after all i care about
is what's at the top of the building but
that scaffolding was needed to be able
to get the thing to the top of the
building
so there are some things that we have
that are a consequence of sort of how
how we grew i mean there are things
where you could say well i don't really
you know that that part of what is there
was sort of just a construction artifact
i mean there are
there are weird cases where for example
for us humans you know
our fingers actually grow in a weird way
they
initially we get the sort of web in in
utero so to speak we
you know there's a the hand is just the
sort of webbed thing
and then actually the cells that are in
between the fingers die off
and so essentially there was scaffolding
which was the whole sort of web
and then a piece of the scaffolding died
off and that's what led us to our
separate fingers
but um they're places where well that
isn't the case
another thing that can happen is even
independent of the growth of an
individual organism
it can be the case that uh you
that biological evolution ends up going
in a certain direction
and even though there might be a better
solution it can't get there from here
so a classic example of that for us
humans is in our eyes
in the retina of our eyes there are
there are
sort of light sensitive cells on the
back of our retina and there are also
some cells
that make connections that start doing
some of the basic image processing that
our eyes use
and we really goofed up because those
cross connections are in front of the
photosensitive cells in our retina
and so it's like that's a dumb idea
because the the photons the light that's
trying to get to our retina
has to go through that level of cross
connections before it gets to the light
sensitive cells
it seems like a bad way to do it why did
we get an eye that was built that way
well because the eye has devolved
separately
in several different places there are
critters i think the um
the the um uh king crabs i think have
this
um their eyes sort of separately evolved
and they got it the right way round
um they um uh they have it so that the
cross connections
are behind the photosynthesis of cells
but if you look at the sort of tree of
life
evolving towards us it's like that flip
around is really hard to do
in other words an organism which says oh
well i'm just going to drop
out those those nerve cells
i'm not even going to have them at all
it's probably not going to be such a
successful organism
its line will die out long before it got
to the sort of full flip around
um uh uh version so in other words
another thing that could happen is not
only can you not be able to get there
in the growth of an individual organism
it can be the case that biological
evolution
just doesn't have a good way to to get
to that kind of optimal condition
and and so that's how you can end up
with these things that that seem like
they don't make sense but they do make
sense given the history of how you had
to get there
with biological evolution because
biological evolution can typically only
make small changes
it's kind of if biological evolution
suddenly says
let's make a human that has two heads
well there's probably a lot else you
have to worry about as soon as you have
a two-headed human
there's a lot of issues that have to go
along with being two-headed
that um have to be taken care of and
just saying
it's two-headed it's probably not gonna
work very well so you can't make that
sort of big
change you have to incrementally make
the change you know butt out the little
tiny
you know sub-head and then slowly over
the course of ten thousand a hundred
thousand
generations you know it gets bigger and
et cetera et cetera et cetera and
eventually you might end up with
the two-headed organism so to speak but
um but it's not going to happen suddenly
and and that's that's a characteristic
of biological evolution the way you can
think about it
in terms of other kinds of things is
imagine that you're trying to find the
best solution
to some mathematical problem you've got
this whole the best solution
you you're trying to say what's the
lowest point in this
landscape let's say and you're trying to
find that by sort of moving around the
landscape you're
you're sort of probing around the
landscape in biological evolution it's
as if
that every time a new organism with
little random mutations
is created it's moving a small distance
randomly on this landscape and the
question is
if you keep doing that and you keep
saying
well i'm gonna i'm gonna be a winner if
i find a little bit closer to you know
further down on the landscape
can you by sort of randomly moving
around like that can you find the
absolute minimum of the landscape well
you might not
you might be stuck in this crater over
here which
where you you say well this seems like
the the lowest point because i
you know i move around randomly i can't
get to a lower point i'd have to go and
walk all the way over this hill
which i'm not to get to this even lower
point over here
and that's just not something that
evolution can do because
if it makes the just those small changes
to keep an organism that's still pretty
fit
around it's never going to get to that
that more global minimum so to speak
and so that's why you end up with these
things that are sort of uh sort of
strange artifacts of the of the history
of life
okay
the um
okay they're comments apparently people
saying that um uh the appendix
apparently it's its use is
storing good bacteria that help
repopulate
uh when needed okay that's interesting i
mean sometimes
it's a challenge because sometimes you
take the sort of
the you just take it for granted that
biological evolution knows best
it's gonna do the right thing and if you
see a phenomenon in biological evolution
then there has to be a reason for it um
and uh and so sometimes that can lead to
very weird conclusions because like
let's find a reason what can it possibly
be you know
why do we have i don't know uh
what's a good example i don't know why
do um uh
uh you know yeah why why do we have the
folds in our ears for example
there has to be a good reason um you
know
i don't know in that particular case i
mean the whole shape of our ear the
whole pinner of our of our sort of
outer ear is um uh you know that's
that's useful because apparently
um because it affects the way that sound
is is brought into our ears
and that helps us distinguish things
like is the sound coming from in front
of us or behind us but
the exact you know details of how sort
of the ear is
is folded up the way it is and the and
the great diversity of those folds
between different people you know uh you
might say well nature knows best
evolution knows best there's got to be a
good reason for that there's going to be
a good reason
for the folding in the ear maybe there
is maybe it's a consequence of the fact
that it's easier to grow ears that way
i mean in a sense when you make do
technology there's this kind of idea of
design for manufacturability
i mean back in the day people would say
i've got this great design i'm going to
make this thing and it's going to have
this little robot it's going to have all
these arms it's going to be this and
this and this
and somebody would specify this is the
robot that i want
and then it would be given to somebody
you know the factory that was going to
make the robot
and they say what do you mean how am i
supposed to make this thing you know how
do i get it you know there's no mold i
can make that will make this thing and
how do i assemble it and you know where
do i how do i get you know how do i
how do i get that little piece in the
middle sort of attached properly and so
on
and so then there was this kind of
methodology that um developed called
design for manufacturability
where people thought about how you're
actually gonna make it and biology in a
sense is
forced to do design for
manufacturability because we grow
and there has to be a way to get to the
way we are by biological growth
and um so that's a that's a thing that
can affect
the things you see as i was mentioning
before and so you know this
that's what biology did it's got to be
good for something
well it might be in some sense just that
way because you ha
you know it grows that way or it might
be that way just because of the
particular history of biology now now
sometimes you wonder
about whether some detail some some big
feature
of biology today might be the
consequence of some bizarre accident
that happened
a billion years ago like for example the
fact that we have five fingers not six
not seven
the fact that there are lots of flowers
and other organisms
that have five-fold symmetry why five
why not six why not seven
um you know maybe that's because well
five is better
it's the optimal point in some whole
elaborate
thing about you know getting food and
grasping things and all that kind of
stuff
well maybe it's could have been five it
could have been seven
but some terrible misfortune happened to
that um
strange little creature that might have
been you know embedded in the burgess
shale from the
from the pre-cambrian or something that
um uh was
uh you know that some terrible
misfortune happened to the seven
symmetry
line of creatures they just got you know
there was some
i don't know some volcano that uh
you know that that uh sort of wiped them
all out and it's purely a matter of
historical chance
that we've ended up with the five uh
sort of the five symmetry things
so there may be things like that we
don't know what things like that might
exist
in the history of biological evolution i
mean we kind of expect that
you know the asteroid impact that wiped
out the dinosaurs
that was kind of a an external
historical accident
and the consequences of that uh you know
might be
things that were an example of this i
mean the fact that
reptiles are not the dominant form of of
life on earth
maybe if it hadn't been for that
asteroid it would be kind of um
uh you know if i'd been talking to you
here it would have been um
uh you know as a stegosaurus or
something
um i think i think actually the days of
the dinosaurs people tend to think was
sort of numbered
um even independent of the um uh um
of of the um of the asteroid impact but
but that's a separate issue
um uh permanentes is saying tailbones
yeah that's a good example of something
which i think
is that way because of the the way
things grow and it's also
it's also i mean again it's so hard to
tell
it's like you know you look at a whale
and whales presumably evolve from things
that walked on land
and it's got some skeletal structure and
you know some of that skeletal structure
is probably a consequence of the history
of that and so on
and um you know maybe there are things
that we have because we used to you know
hang in trees a lot most of us don't
these days um you know lots and lots of
uh
of details like that that um are you
know historical
features now it's always interesting to
see in terms of evolution
you know bio biology is not the only
place where evolution is seen it's also
seen in technology
and you can ask questions about you know
is the technology that we see the
consequence of some
strange path of historical evolution you
know is the fact that
well very very obviously and simply the
fact that we have a picture of a trash
can
as our uh no that's a bad example the
save icon for example that's a classic
example i
i hope there are enough people who are
young enough on on this live stream
that the save icon might seem weird to
you the save icon that people often use
is this picture of a square thing with a
little in
you know side indent type thing what is
that
icon maybe i actually haven't seen them
so often recently but i'm sure they
still exist
the save icon what on earth is that well
that's a floppy disk it's a picture of a
floppy disk we don't use floppy disks
anymore
and um i have to say the um uh
uh there was probably oh when was it
must be nearly 10 years ago now
i remember showing a floppy disk to a
kid
young kid and the kids saying is that a
3d print out of the save icon
and that was i thought that was a moment
as sort of a watershed in history where
no actually it used to be an actual
thing that you store data on it is
this actual floppy disk is a thing you
store data on the
the save icon is a derivative of that
sort of
piece of history of computing that um
that was the thing where you store data
but but there are many other features of
technology that
are the effective of sort of history i
mean there's some that are burnt in like
the
you know the the width of a railway you
know the distance between the rails on a
railway
you know that's something where it's
it's burnt in because the infrastructure
is built that way it's very hard to
change
but you know that's something that's
sort of a historically determined thing
or or the fact that i don't know if it's
still the case but i think you might
still
be able you know control alt delete you
know that's sort of an arbitrary
thing that you press on windows type
computers to reboot them
that's again sort of a weird historical
random accident
that it is that way and no doubt there
are um
uh the um there are good things to
to to do these are comments that a
floppy disk would be a good thing to 3d
print yeah you can
you can really confuse people with that
you can give them the 3d printout and
then say
do you have a you know put it in your
antique computer what's going to happen
and so on
i have to say back come at the uh
i'm reminded of the the 30th anniversary
of mathematica
uh a couple years ago um the um
uh uh we had a party and um
somebody had made these um uh this sort
of
thing with uh celebrating the first
version of mathematica
and there were edible floppy disks so
these were um
uh so that was another sort of
cognitively difficult thing is you know
you know what a floppy disk is
you have this thing it looks like a
floppy disk and actually you eat it and
it has
icing on it and so on so that's kind of
a weird thing
um oh i see the the the idea is floppy
contains a 3d
rendering of a printout of the floppy
yeah well you know look there are really
strange things like for example
the first computer that i used back in
1972 um used paper tape
as its way of storing information and
we're about to make a virtual machine
recreation
of that uh computer the elliott 903 a
very obscure kind of computer
um and somebody was asking me okay if we
make this recreation
of the software how are you going to
read in your your
paper tape and i realized the obvious
way to read in the paper tape
is to just you know unroll it take a
picture of it
and just use image processing to decide
where all the holes are in the paper
tape
i just have to to say mention one other
thing which i find kind of fun
the um uh back in the day
when was this probably 1980-ish
it was a spacecraft sent uh the voyager
spacecraft um which is um
uh well now the the furthest away human
artifact
that is still in communication i think
with uh with us i think the pioneer
spacecraft are further away but they're
no longer in communication
but the voyager spacecraft is sort of
the the furthest away
human artifact but um i think it was
carl sagan had the
uh was was tasked with put something on
that spacecraft so that if the aliens
find it
um they'll be able to decode features of
human civilization
so famously there was this kind of um uh
this um this golden record that was
you know a circular disc disc shaped
thing and it contained um
all kinds of interesting diagrams and
all that kind of thing
um and uh it um
it was some uh and the idea was
that this was a a record like a vinyl
record
and so how does the vinyl record work
well um
uh for those who don't know i mean it's
you know it's a thing for playing sound
it's the
it's the long predecessor of the mp3
which
and the predecessor of the cd and so on
and the idea was
that you have this this thing and it
rotates it
made a plastic it has this groove in the
plastic
it's a it's a um uh it's a it's a spiral
groove
and what happens is there's a there's a
head that is a little tiny needle
that kind of rides in that spiral groove
and as the
as the thing turns around it's kind of
being moved from the um
uh from the outside to the inside of the
spiral groove
and the whole point is that in the
spiral groove it's not
flat at the bottom of this kind of
valley that is the spiral groove
that it goes up and down and as it goes
up and down
that changes the pressure on the needle
at the tip of this sort of head that's
riding on the
on the on the groove and as that
pressure changes
you can convert that into sound and so
you can play your favorite uh music for
example that way
and so certainly when i was a kid that
was the way that one uh
had music that had been recorded was
with these vinyl records
and they would rotate around and there
were um
let's see there were the 33
am i remembering right the the 33
revolutions per minute and there were
60 gosh i'm forgetting all this stuff
there were there were different
um standards for depending on with a big
long playing record or a smaller one
different standards for the um
uh um uh for the for the um
uh for for um um what
um uh for what the um
uh for how fast the record would go
around and so on because if you
if you made the record go around at
double speed you'd be playing the music
at double speed and you
and all the frequencies would be double
double the frequencies you'd be going up
an octave in in the
in the music so to speak but anyway so
back in 1980
everybody knew about vinyl records and
everybody knew
how you would you know play a vinyl
record and it seemed kind of obvious you
have these grooves
and you have this thing and it's moving
around and so carl sagan was like
well if the extraterrestrials find this
they'll realize it's a record and
they'll be able to play it
and they recorded on that record sort of
all kinds of sounds from earth of
music and and different human languages
and all kinds of things
and it's got a lot of data on it of that
kind okay
so and they actually had this diagram
which is kind of like the instruction
diagram of how to play
this this record with a sort of picture
of what the head looks like and it's
kind of a spiral thing
and so on and so on and so on okay so
now we're
you know uh 40 something years later and
it's like
that's a really goofy thing because it's
like a record
you know a vinyl like record who would
ever think of doing that that's really
old technology
and so for example if we picked up that
record today what we actually do with it
to well probably what we do is we get
high resolution imagery
that basically picks out the depth of
that channel
at every point in the spiral channel and
we then just do image processing
and we'd figure out and we'd have to do
this nasty awkward piece of image
processing where we unroll
the spiral and we'd say gosh it's a big
nuisance they put the thing in a spiral
why didn't they just put it in
scan lines you know rectangularly along
the page
um but you know we unroll the spiral and
then we can we can finally
listen to that music but so it's
interesting in just 40 years
how that kind of the the evolution of
technology
has taken us to the point where what
seemed like obvious very robust
technology
of how everybody would know how to play
a a vinyl-like record
has transitioned into something that is
really quite obscure and of course
cds for example work differently they
didn't have a spiral groove
they worked with concentric rings and so
on and the different different
setup um and so so it's a lot of
interesting to see how that works and to
see that that
particular technology of spiral grooves
i don't think has really been
that there isn't a you know that has i
think pretty much died out
um but other things are are still being
sort of grandfathered
forward um because you know it's it's
too difficult to change or whatever else
okay well i think i should probably wrap
up here
um gosh i left so many interesting uh
questions um here um
and uh um yeah
lots of interesting questions well i
look forward to to addressing a bunch of
these um
next time so i should uh
um oh
that's some interesting one from
uh william here i'm gonna try and
address that next time
um okay well thanks for joining us and
um
uh same time next week
bye until then
me
you